hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play cry of fear okay I noticed on
the save that this is a mental hospital
sad that bodes well for me [ __ ] it Oh
bye let's see now the gate under the
stairs is open and now I can make my way
through to whatever dastardly hell
awaits me huh oh hey a bowling alley
cool
I found a Glock magazine which hopefully
means that a Glock will be nearby can
eyeball his physics implemented enough
oh there it is
haha P 3545 I don't I'll have that I'll
put it on my bar no yeah I only have a
guy I only picked up a Glock magazine
nothing else
I'll go back to the stick to our new
wheel gun and stick combo that's
effective ha ha ha I got no now oh just
die die you're not doing anything yeah
yeah here oh sorry yes oh I have a bit
of a cough this morning hopefully that
coffee I had earlier last month isn't
coming back
ah syringe okay I need that anyway so
I'll drop my stick for the moment yes Oh
chomp down a big all dose a goodie
goodness ha ha boom I'm wondering if the
mental hospital is like you know the
mental hospital where Simon was
stationed at and had to be caught and
was there something else in that room
that I missed just double check more
bowling balls why is there a bowling
alley in a mental hospital I don't know
okay moving on oh there we go
there's something see rain strange about
dr. Pernilla uh-huh
dr. Pernell could it be yes that would
be your dr. Simon and the doctor even
following wonk wonk wonk nope completely
immobile oh wow now I learned his name
oh hey I don't have a gun you [ __ ]
you shoot yourself in the head you did
didn't you
okay I gotta drop this to pick up this
other gun that's okay
they give me more Glock ammo than they
do that ammo anyway so it's all good all
right get some ready for you now
oh I'll sight down I can't sighs you
[ __ ] you can you took away all my
help you half bag you son of a [ __ ]
don't care if I wasted ammo on you you
drop me like I had full health
you [ __ ] now I'm slow oh you son of a
[ __ ] okay I don't have a bag branch I
guess I can't believe you oh there we go
another one okay drop the shotgun first
oh shut up Simon you big pansy if I got
shot by ten bullets I wouldn't be crying
about it
that a door okay sealed shut
well that was useful I got my first if I
need to do Mele let's see what's going
on
who wants some fired or shoot
Oh Chet okay I only went in there to get
some guns that it nothing down here
that's where the basement was have you
double-checked
I wish I generally I wish I had some
sort of a bag back would be a real nice
nothing else down here
a lot o generator won't that's probably
if it's caused something in the upper
floors that got unlocked as well because
I don't think there was anything else
besides to behind the great glad I got a
gun though quiet quiet
hello
did I have her go upstairs oh the great
open upstairs okay huh it's some mental
hospital hi daki oh yeah talk I talk
about bullets no don't do it
she's got a gun the subway look just
open the gates will you I'm tired of all
this oh oh he wants the
I want the
that's kind of weird I know should I
give him the gun what happen if I give
him the gun what does he want with the
gun anyway he's a doctor he's supposed
to help people
I need back spaces oh shut up
yeah we're we're we're there another way
around do I have to give them the gun
there's more upstairs let me go up there
ah no aha
no suicidally influencing me okay how's
her
doors locked with a key back long-long
long-long okay
um
maybe that's the other way around or
maybe that's later I don't really know
check problems here I don't know I'll go
get him the gun drop my gun though I
like my god Wow where'd you come from
hi hi no Chuck guns joggin fu where's my
jacket fine fine fine
you get bullets to the face that's weird
you gotta get a pot you have paper on
your head that's that's scary
that's totally scary man down here I'm
going crazy just like Simon yes here
okay
in divulging alley well actually it's
not in the bowling alley
I'll drop the shotgun for now I'll come
back and get it I'll be down I got you
your gun God shouldn't trust this guy
I shouldn't trust this guy
got you your gun I don't think I can
trust you what
whoops no no I want to give him the gun
no I want to give him the gun man I want
to give him the gun hi hang on I want to
go back I want to go back cuz I actually
want to give him the gun I didn't know
that saying no would just denying the
gun outright and I'm gonna give him the
gun see what happens
cuz I'm interested I'm interested if
this doctor if he's actually Simon's
doctor and if I'm thinking of this in a
not insane way then
Simon's doctor is actually trying to
help him right what why is it so dark
oh I need to be loaded Oh so dark this
is a crazy accent okay there we go all
right okay yeah I wanna see what happens
if he is if yes if in real life cuz this
I figured out that this isn't reality
and his doctor is his psychiatrist that
means then that the guy is trying to
help him like really but he just seems
like Simon in his crazy state that he's
not trying to help but if he trusts him
and shows him trust and that'll be
getting also he shot me afterwards
either way so that would just give if he
didn't trust him then that would
reinforce Simon's image that he didn't
trust him and that's why in Simon's mind
he shot him
maybe or maybe I'm just crazy probably
actually I'm gonna I'm gonna make a
whole new save right before this
decision just just in case so because
it's a first decision that I've ever had
so there's gonna be I'm gonna never save
on slot five ever again that's gonna be
reserved for this okay
let's see what happened yes
there's no
high dose shot me kill you oh come on
really on now my now my health is
permanently low I gotta go back and get
my shotgun
so either way he shoots you but I think
it's important to show that Simon trusts
his doctor
maybe maybe I know that's just it it's
is it the area I have does it make sense
if all this is just in his head then the
doctor should only be trying to help him
okay hmm dark again
back up one more
get my shotgun got my pistol hi
No haha those are some big showcases so
now I've got permanently lower house
maybe I should just shop together
another key find a phone number what the
hell
this I'm gonna find us really
I can't see a thing
okay I'm on that window okay no I'm on a
far window to the left just hurry up
there's another window weights are like
lightning oh there nothing there nothing
there that's pouring it up
look here lightning lightning for called
down the Thunder
anything nothing
over here lightning ha ha
damn it why something here
or maybe it's not in a windmill but
I got to go on come on lightning you
ah all right well that that was a way of
your time all right I gotta cut it here
thank you guys so much for watching and
there's nothing thank you guys so much
for watching that's always see you in
the next one bye bye